COLLEEN MCGINNESS:
--and board members.
A 1997 graduate, Kerry has
been a member of the alumni
executive board for six years.
She has served as secretary,
vice president, and now
president.
On behalf of the Alumni
Board and the entire Alumni
Association, I wish to thank
her for her loyal service.
She's done an outstanding job
leading the Alumni Association
Board during a difficult time.
She's been the right
person in the right seat
to keep our volunteers engaged.
Kerry and her husband Richard
reside in Glenview, Illinois.
They have four grown children
and three grandchildren.
Please join me in
welcoming Kerry.
[APPLAUSE]
KERRY CUMMINGS:
Thank you, Colleen.
It is my privilege to
introduce Dr. Larry
Arnn, who is in his 21st year
as president of Hillsdale.
[APPLAUSE]
During this time,
Dr. Arnn has overseen
the unprecedented
growth of the college
both in the physical plant
and in the development
of its academic and
outreach efforts.
The college has emerged
in the last 21 years
as truly a nationally ranked
undergraduate institution
with over 70% of students now
enrolling from out of state
and a near 20%
rate of admission.
Under Dr. Arnn's
leadership, millions
are now able to access
Hillsdale's classical liberal
arts education through the
development of the college's
vast outreach efforts.
These include the
Van Andel Graduate
School of Statesmanship,
Van Andel Graduate School
of Government Hillsdale in
DC, the Churchill Project,
the Halter Shooting Sports
Center, the Gordon Biology
Station, 30 online
courses, the establishment
of Hillsdale K-12 with
40 affiliated schools
across the country,
the new Blake
Center for Faith and
Freedom, and the growth
of the college's flagship
publication, Imprimus,
to more than 6 million readers.
Dr. Arnn has published widely
on the issues of public policy
and political theory, is past
president of the Philadelphia
Society, is a
member of the board
of trustees for the
Heritage Foundation
and the board of directors
of the Henry Salvatore
Center of Claremont McKenna
College, the Intercollegiate
Studies Institute, and
the Claremont Institute.
In 2015, Dr. Arnn
received the Bradley Prize
from the Lindy and Harry
Bradley Foundation.
Recently, he was appointed to
former President Trump's 1776
Commission, which
was established
to restore in American education
an understanding of the history
and the principles of the
founding of the United States.
Published widely in
newspapers and magazines
and periodicals on issues
of public policy, history,
and political theory,
Dr. Arnn is the author
of three books,
Liberty and Learning,
the Evolution of the American
Education, The Founders' Key,
the Divine and
Natural Connection
between the Declaration
and the Constitution
and What We Risk By Losing It,
and Churchill's Trial, Winston
Churchill and the Salvation
of Free Government.
Dr. Arnn travels tirelessly
to educate others and raise
support for the
college, yet he still
finds time to
frequent the cafeteria
and have lunch with students
as well as teach classes
in politics and history.
He and his wife Penny
have four children--
Henry, Katie, Alice, and Tony--
and recently welcomed their
first grandchild Charlotte.
Please join me in welcoming
our dedicated and accomplished
president, Dr. Larry Arnn.
[APPLAUSE]
LARRY ARNN: Neal Cole,
are you not a Sigma Chi?
Are you a Sigma Chi?
And he's skipping the
40th birthday party.
Well done.
Welcome back.
Thank you, Colleen,
and thank you, Kerry.
It's a joy to see you all.
It's a measure of the continuity
of the college to have you all.
The college is continuous.
It's looks like we're going
to get to have college again
next year.
I recognize two new--
Bill Nolan is not here.
He's with the Sigma Chis.
Are you here, Bill Nolan?
No.
There's three new
trustees, and two are here.
And I'm going to ask
them to stand up.
Bill-- forget Bill
Nolan, he didn't come.
Donna Acton and
David Huff are here.
And would they stand up please?
[APPLAUSE]
And I recognize the recipients.
Two of them I know well.
Two of them are too old.
I'll prove how well
I know them and then
I'll praise the other two.
Jared Veldheer is the best
football player we ever had.
The second best is John
Sweeney, who's here tonight--
[APPLAUSE]
--whom we learned today is the
first academic All-American
in Hillsdale College history.
And nobody mentioned
at the board meeting
because somebody
brought that up that he
was both kinds of All-American.
And I don't know if Jared
was both kinds or not.
Jared was like John,
an offensive lineman.
And John and I revel in the fact
that on the Wonderlic IQ test
the offensive linemen
are the smartest.
And I was an offensive
lineman, I just
wasn't very good
at being a lineman.
And there are two games
that mark in my memory
the excellence of the man.
And one was we beat
Grand Valley State, won
the conference that year, and
we beat them with a long drive
where we ran over and
over on the left side.
And because I was a
lineman and because I
love football in the
frustrated way somebody
loves it who was never
all that good at it,
I watched him block the left
side of the line of Grand
Valley State.
It was just awesome.
And they have a
very fancy scheme.
And the linebackers are
fast and they move around.
And the linemen stop things
up and then they dart in.
Well, he just blocked
the guy in front of him,
and the linebacker, too.
And he did it over and over.
It was obvious, right?
And then we played
in the playoffs
the first game, Mankato State,
and when the offensive line
came out they didn't
look like oxen,
they looked like
mineral deposits.
They were enormous.
And the way they did it,
you can see, by the way,
that my method, my
approach to football
was to try to think it through.
And so I noticed things, right?
And they would all start
in a similar direction
and they'd try to get momentum
and they'd try to run over us.
And I said to Jared after the
game, how did you stop them?
And you know that was
his cue to say, well,
we worked really hard and all
that stuff, and we trained
or something.
That's what they say
in all the interviews.
No, he didn't.
He said, you take this foot
and you move it right over here
and then you go like this.
He was giving me instruction how
to play in the offensive line.
And the last thing
about him is when
he joined the Oakland Raiders
there were articles about him.
And the articles always
mentioned something
about what a nice and
well-spoken young man he was.
And this is the NFL,
they're not used to that.
And the Raiders least of all.
So I'm proud of him.
Joy Pullmann is a journalist
and I had her husband in class.
I never had her.
She was too good for me.
And she's won national fame
and she's a very fierce woman.
And she's insightful,
and she's tough,
and she loves her
family and the family,
and she loves good
education and her education.
And she writes about those
things with real conviction,
so I'm proud of her.
Oh, Ron Gladnick.
Where's Gladnick?
Yeah, so I met him
through John Servini.
And they're just alike
except I think Gladnick may
be richer and Servini smarter.
And what are you doing now?
Yeah, you sold your company
and got a lot of dough.
And he's just agreed to
give a very large gift
to Hillsdale College--
or has he?
[LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE]
I did that on behalf of John.
[LAUGHS] Congratulations to you.
And he was a big jock and
he looks like it, too.
He was really great.
OK, come on.
Where else am I?
Our last recipient,
I don't know him.
And where is he?
Right here.
And he's a very successful man.
And I looked up some
stuff about him,
and the people who worked with
and for him like him a lot.
And he's going to give
a great talk tonight.
I look forward to that.
And because of that, I'll
shut up pretty quick.
I just want to tell
you, Hillsdale College
has never been more threatened
and never been more successful.
Things are underway
in Washington D.C.
that will shift yet
more from the private
to the public sector.
They're very interested
in controlling
charitable giving these days.
And surely that will not
be allowed to happen,
but if it is, surely we will
find a way to survive that.
But in the face
of all that, it's
just marvelous to us
what's happened here.
I'm not going to state numbers,
but giving to Hillsdale College
has risen every year
for 21 years in a row.
But there have
been two big jumps,
both in the middle of a crisis.
And after the first crisis it
didn't fall off after that.
So I'm hoping, because
this jump is bigger
and I'm hoping it doesn't
fall off after this jump,
and that makes amazing
things possible.
It basically means
that we can pay
for the excellence around here.
We hired 21 new faculty
members this year.
We set out to get 16, and the
applications were so great
that we would hire two where
we were only meant to hire one,
and I'm the one who
got carried away.
People from the Ivy League are
begging to come to work here.
And why?
Because the kids are smart,
and they're respectful,
and they do the
work, and everybody
is nice to each other.
In other words, it
acts like a college.
And if somebody's
not nice to somebody,
then we'll speak to them.
But that hardly ever happens.
The entering scores
of the freshman class,
which is 75 students over
budget, that's 20% over budget,
are the highest
ever, and one point
below the averages of Harvard.
And we could match
Harvard if we wanted to
if we just adopted the
practice of admitting everybody
who makes a perfect score
on the entrance exams.
But we always turn
down six or eight or 10
of those, 10 in the
last year, and we do it
because they come in here acting
like they're God's gift to man.
And we remind them that there
are only 17 or 18 years old.
My favorite question is,
what can you possibly know?
And you know we
really pat ourselves
on the back about
things like that.
The college is successful.
And the college is
reaching everywhere.
That's an element
of its success.
We have 20 charter schools,
we have 11 in process.
We're getting ready to try
to form 50 in Tennessee
at the request of the
governor of Tennessee.
And to pursue that idea--
I mean he called me up and said
you're coming to Nashville.
And I said, I am?
And he said, come see me.
So I go.
He gives us lunch,
and he said a prayer.
He had his whole senior
management there,
including one kid named
Gursky who's a Hillsdale kid--
Kelvin be quiet.
After he said his
prayer he said,
we need Hillsdale
College in Tennessee.
And I said, Governor, Hillsdale
College is very heavy and hard
to move.
And he said, I know.
But he said, you're starting
these education centers.
We have one in D.C. that's a
graduate school and thriving
and we have one in Somers,
Connecticut, that has
a replica of Monticello on it.
And we know a million
people on our mailing list
who live within a 90-minute
drive at that place.
So we're going to
have stuff there,
and we're going to teach.
And there's about to be one, I
do believe, in Placer County,
California, North of Sacramento.
And this morning's
news is that there
might be another one outside
Fresno on the King River
where it comes out
of the Sierras.
Very beautiful place.
And that's all
stupid and difficult,
but those things bring a
lot of money with them.
And so I'm not trained
in being a businessman,
but I know enough
about it to know
you don't take your
existing revenues
and spread them over
a larger expense base.
So we don't have to.
Why are those things happening?
Oh, online courses.
Half a million people new
signed up for those last year.
And there are 3
million total now.
And the percentage that finished
the courses and take the exams
is rising all the time.
I get stopped in airports now
saying, I'm taking your course.
And then sometimes they're
70, sometimes they're 30,
sometimes they're 15, and
they act like students.
They often have a question,
they make a comment.
And if you ask them if
they're taking their exams
and how they're doing,
they turn into freshmen.
They look at their feet
and look embarrassed.
These are treasures.
And they're happening here.
And it's unprecedented.
I don't think that's
an exaggeration.
It's important for us to
remember who owns the college.
Have you ever asked
yourself that question?
Who owns the college?
General Motors belongs to
its stockholders, right?
Hillsdale College
is 177 years old,
and it's been under the same
ownership all that time.
The owners are named in the
beautiful founding document
of the college, as
they are, by the way,
in the founding of every
charity in the nation.
The college belongs to its
beneficiaries, the people
it names in its founding
document, in its charter
that it intends to benefit.
Who are those people?
Every student.
But every student
down through time.
That means, we pray, millions
unborn, every employee,
of course.
We serve it and we get
paid, but we owe it, too.
That means all the
citizens whose freedom
is to be reinforced by the
teachings of the college.
This is all said in
the founding document.
Every Christian who
wants to practice
an intelligent form
of piety, the college
belongs to all of them.
The reason the board of
trustees is important
is because their charge
is to act for all of them,
to keep them in mind every day.
We who run the college, we
try to keep them in mind, too,
but some days it's an emergency.
There are 1,600 kids here.
God knows what they're
going to do on any given
day, although they
behave better than you
did when you were here.
This bunch-- I feel really old--
this bunch sitting right here I
remember them distinctly
when they were students.
And I'm astonished that
they're still alive.
SPEAKER 1: They got married.
LARRY ARNN: They did.
They got married.
And like Jody Lindt, he was a
boy given to self-reflection.
He's a classics major.
He's actually very intelligent,
although you can't tell it
by looking at him.
And he would come
in my office often,
and he would agonize
about whether he's
doing the right thing or not.
He's a classics major.
The specific
purpose of the major
is to answer the question,
what is the right thing?
Ridiculous.
The Articles of
Association say that we
are going to perpetuate
the blessings
of civil and religious
liberty and intelligent piety.
The claim is that
those are eternal goods
and they are worthy of
eternal preservation.
Who's responsible to do that?
Come to find out,
above all it is we
who have enjoyed its benefits.
When you were students here,
you paid a small fraction
of the cost of it.
But that's not the cost.
The cost is work and
thinking and conversation
and concentration and alertness.
And a commitment, if
you study the things
we teach here, to keep
thinking about those
for the rest of your life.
So what?
So you can live them and
teach them to others.
This year, we just
got our audit today,
and this year the
students have paid
for 6% of the cost
of Hillsdale College.
And that's right,
actually, as long
as they remember to
be grateful for that.
Because the funds have
been supplied by literally
millions of people
who get nothing for it
except a share in the pursuit
of the love that we represent
and share here actively.
Hillsdale College is
a massive community.
It encompasses people
by the tens of millions
in every corner of the land.
And millions of people
pin their hopes on it.
We are the ones who have
received its benefits the most
richly.
We are the ones who owe those
who haven't, who never get to.
I remember one year, there
were stirrings around
because a CCA audience
now from outside
is like 600 or 800 people.
And the people who
come are very annoying.
They asked dumb questions.
And we built this
auditorium and this
so they can have a place to sit.
And a very nice
young woman, an RA,
when I talk every
time at the beginning
of every term to
the RAs, and that's
always an inspiring experience
because they're the best.
And this young woman said to
me two years ago she said--
and I was about to leave.
I said, anything else?
And I had picked up my
coat and my briefcase,
and she said, why do we have
to have these visitors here?
Isn't this for us?
And the record shows
that I put my coat down
and my briefcase and I answered
that question for 30 minutes.
And I explained to her about
the obligation she has,
because she could never
pay for this you see,
and she has to eat,
and has to live,
and has to have shelter
and all that stuff,
and everybody around
here has got to be paid.
And I said, do you see
the obligation you have?
They come here to do
a little bit of what
you get to immerse yourself in.
Don't you owe them?
You should teach them.
And I know they
ask dumb questions
because they're not like us.
They're not in the military.
They're civilians and
we're Marines here, right?
We train, we get ready,
we concentrate for years.
I say, when they
ask a dumb question,
go introduce yourself
and teach them something.
Help them understand.
You want to live
in a free country?
That understanding
standing needs to grow
and it needs to grow fast.
And it all starts right here.
Thank you for coming back.
[APPLAUSE]
KERRY CUMMINGS:
Thank you Dr. Arnn.
The Hillsdale College
Alumni Association
was organized at the
close of the Civil War.
Think about that.
Alumni back then
saw the importance
of supporting the college.
Upon its founding,
the Association
adopted its own
mission statement,
which called upon its members to
keep the alumni fully informed,
help maintain the
standards of the college,
aid in the enrollment
of new students,
and encourage all alumni
to tangibly support
the college by
developing programs
to ensure its continued growth.
That is our same mission today.
Today, our 30-member
Alumni Association Board
works hard on behalf of the more
than 15,000 Alumni Association
members to honor and uphold
this 152-year-old commitment.
For 70 years, it's
been a tradition
to hold this banquet to
recognize the achievement
and service of some of our
most outstanding graduates,
and that's what brings
us here tonight.
But before we transition
to honoring those awardees,
I'd like to take a few minutes
to acknowledge and thank
members of the Alumni
Association Board
who are finishing their
final year of service.
These members all have
served two four-year terms
and have dedicated
their time and expertise
to the college in
a variety of ways.
We're very grateful
for their service
and for their love and
enthusiasm for our alma mater.
The following members were not
able to join us this evening--
Tyler Horning, Scott Kenan,
Mark Donovan and Andrew Fink.
But I would like to call
those two members up here,
Maryann Ratoli, class of 1995,
and Richard Rockett Kyocera,
of class of 1976.
I'd like you to come
up so I can present you
with a gift on
behalf of the college
and formally thank you for your
service to Hillsdale College.
[APPLAUSE]
On behalf of
Hillsdale College, we
want to thank you
for your service
by presenting you with this
beautiful watercolor of Central
Hall.
[APPLAUSE]
Well, it looks like I
may have moved forward
a little bit faster
than I meant to.
Let's begin this evening
will be recognizing
four Outstanding Alumni.
Their achievements are
detailed in your table programs
and I encourage
you to read those,
if you have not
already done so, I'll
make an introduction of
each honoree that will
be followed by a short video.
These videos have been
added in the last few years,
and I think they're just
fabulous ways of presenting
our honorees to all of you.
After that, Dr. Arnn and I
will present each recipient
with an award,
and each recipient
will be asked to make
remarks if they wish.
And Jared, I know you
already volunteered
to make those remarks, so you're
going to be kicking this off.
He wanted you to know right
away what number he was,
and I said, well, we're starting
with you so you set that tone.
Our first honoree is Jared
Veldheer, class of 2009.
Jared is a retired--
Oh, his table would like to
applaud at the beginning.
Thank you.
Again, he's setting the tone.
Jared is a retired
NFL offensive tackle
and was a four-year
starter at Hillsdale.
He was named First Team
All GLEAC in 2008 and 2009
and First Team All-American by
the American Football Coaches
Association in 2009.
He helped Hillsdale qualify
for the NCAA Division II
playoffs for the
first time in 2009
and advanced to
the second round.
In his 46 Hillsdale
starts at left tackle,
he never allowed a sack and
the Chargers had their two
highest-scoring seasons
up until that point
in history 2007 and 2009.
Jared was a third-round draft
pick in the Oakland Raiders
69th overall in
the 2010 NFL draft.
In March 2014 he signed
a five-year contract
with the Arizona Cardinals.
In 2015, the Cardinals
finished with a 13 and 3 record
and had the highest-scoring
offense in the NFL.
Jared was named team
MVP by his teammates
after that 2014 season.
He left the Cardinals
in 2017 and went on
to play with the Denver
Broncos, the New England
Patriots, the Green Bay Packers,
and the Indianapolis Colts
before retiring from
the NFL in 2021.
Jared is a native of Grand
Rapids, majored in biology,
and belonged to the Delta
Sigma Phi fraternity.
He now serves as Director
of Health and Wellness
for Strategies Wealth Advisors
and is an active craft beer
brewer.
He says thank you for that.
His wife, Morgan,
also a 2012 graduate,
are active volunteers
and generous supporters
of the college in many ways.
They have two children,
Eva and Edwin,
and please give your
attention to the screen
to meet our distinguished
alumni honoree, Jared Veldheer.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JARED VELDHEER: As
an offensive lineman,
you're always working
behind the scenes.
You know how to
handle success humbly,
because when you
have that success,
your name's not going to be
printed in a newspaper article.
Maybe you get a shout
out, the whole line
is a unit would get a shout
out from the running backs,
quarterbacks, coaches, whatever.
But we knew to never get
too high off our success,
never get too low if there is
any kind of failure, that it
just really took five guys
to grind day in, day out
and look to keep getting
better and build as a unit.
My name is Jared Veldheer.
I grew up in Grand Rapids,
Michigan, born and raised.
Football, even
professional football,
I didn't really see
that in my future much.
Like maybe college football, but
I liked basketball a lot more.
Coach Otterbein came and watched
one of my basketball games
and then offered
me a scholarship
to play football after and
I accepted pretty quick
because I was already
familiar with the school.
My brother went there and
played basketball there.
I could see the value in
being at an institution
like that for four-plus years.
The NFL thought first popped in
my head after my freshman year.
I was able to put on some
good size, strength, and speed
and a couple of guys just
started joking about it like,
hey, you're just as big as these
guys that are getting drafted
or in the combine and
they're playing in the NFL.
And it never seemed
too stressful
and it just seemed kind
of a lighthearted fun goal
to go about.
We finished our football
season in November
and then immediately
I signed with an agent
and that whole
process started to go.
Heard my name called
with the 69th pick
in the draft, which
was the third round.
Just kind of a whirlwind,
just instant elation and then
just craziness.
Looking back at the
transition between Division II
and the NFL, getting moved from
left tackle the right tackle
probably sticks out is
the biggest challenge
because I played left tackle
my whole time at Hillsdale
and played left tackle for the
first seven years of the NFL
career.
And when I took those
initial right tackle sets
and I just felt so awkward.
My body was just so
programmed to move
from a left-handed stance.
I wanted to basically
quit in training camp
because I felt like I
was just so worthless
and that I was no longer
one of those five guys
I was accountable
to one another,
and that I couldn't
do my job, and I
didn't want to do that to
the group and the team.
And it's never fun when you
have to learn through playing
in front of 60,000-plus
people, but, again,
just kind of keep
your head down,
and try to get better and
correct things and fix it
as you go.
And that's what I did
and figured it out.
And so it's nice being able
to take some of those lessons
and now try to apply them
outside of football, trying
to raise a young
family and you know now
being back in West Michigan,
and just life changing sometimes
you feel like you can
maybe lose your footing.
But with what I've
learned, I'm able to stay
grounded, if that makes sense.
Something that everyone
who's gone to Hillsdale
has heard a million
times: it's the people.
And I think it really
applies, because
without that great
group of people there,
I don't know how many people
would stick around and survive
and thrive and have a
really good academic career,
athletic career, whatever it is.
It's a tough place.
So it was a losing
record my freshman year.
And then it seemed like each
year, I think it was each year,
we had gotten better,
improved, and then
my senior year we had made it
to the Division II playoffs
for the first time
in school history.
And Coach Otterbein
was a great coach.
I really tip my hat to
him being able to work
with 18- to 22-year-old
kids and turn them into men.
And I think that was
always his number one goal.
And when you're going through
the same kind of challenges,
the same difficulties,
the same stages of life,
and you're doing it
together nonstop,
you just forge some really
special relationships.
And I was definitely able
to do that at Hillsdale.
Not trying to put words in
your mouth, Coach Otter,
but if you can mold those good
men, those good human beings,
that the wins would follow that.
Because that was the
most important piece.
Without that then the
wins wouldn't happen.
[APPLAUSE]
KERRY CUMMINGS: Jared.
Will you please come forward?
And Dr. Arnn?
I'll have you stand here and
Dr. Arnn will be next to you.
Jared, on behalf of
the Alumni Association
of Hillsdale College,
it's my great honor
to present you with a--
[LAUGHTER]
--Distinguished
Alumni Achievement
Award for Professional
Athletics.
Congratulations.
[APPLAUSE]
LARRY ARNN: Just
right now I doubt
the truth of the statement
the bigger they are,
the harder they fall.
[LAUGHTER]
JARED VELDHEER: I don't think
any tall people said that.
No, where's Mr. Lantis?
What happened to the
revision on the--
I am no longer the
Strategies Wealth Advisors
Health and Wellness Consultant.
I have now moved on to
bigger and better things.
I am the school lunch lady for
St. Paul the Apostle Elementary
School in Grand Rapids.
I got the blisters to
prove it on my hands
from stirring up a
40-pound batch of Sloppy
Joes over the last two days.
Yeah, that's where
I am right now.
How I got there?
This place, this college
played a big part.
It taught me a lot
of great lessons that
have helped mold
me into who I am
into the friend, the father,
the spouse, the son, brother,
whatever it is in life.
I've been able to take
away great lessons
from this school
in the classroom,
on the football field,
in the mule room, just
random conversations.
There's so much that you take in
when you're a part of Hillsdale
and Hillsdale College.
One of the biggest things is
perseverance and preparedness.
I think those are two
important pieces in life.
And with those you
can overcome anything
because you have a
plan and then you
can get through that
plan, whatever happens.
My most recent story with that,
really over the last two years,
I planned on being done with
football, being retired,
but I've always been
kind of a fitness junkie,
so I stayed in decent enough
shape and got to the point
where I got kind of itchy
towards the end of the season
and asked my agent
if anybody needed
help, and so I was
somewhat prepared.
But the last go-round with
the Indianapolis Colts
was a little different.
It was the day after Christmas,
it was a previous O-line coach,
and I got in the car,
they needed help.
I went down there since
Christmas Day was done.
I couldn't go back on Christmas
plans with the family,
it was our first
one back at home.
So the GM actually reached
out earlier in December
and I told him we'd have to
circle back after Christmas.
Well, day after Christmas I'm
in the car going down to Indy,
and I was just told they
needed help on the O-line
and I was willing to
pitch in and put my hand
in the pile, whatever it took.
But when I got down
there, they made
it clear that they really
needed a line, and they're like,
do you think you can learn
this and start the next week?
And I was like, oh yeah
sure, yeah, let's do it.
Why not?
And so I'm in the hotel.
There's a five-day COVID
protocol where you're just
sitting in a hotel
doing COVID testing
and you can't be with the team.
You can do Zoom meetings,
that kind of stuff.
So my first day in the
building was a Thursday.
And to put it in some
perspective, you play Sunday.
And so I get there on
Thursday, meet all the players
for the first time in
person, actually have
one legitimate practice, have
kind of a glorified walkthrough
on Friday, true
walkthrough on Saturday,
and start the game on Sunday.
And I kind of pinched myself
all the way through it,
because I was like,
this is crazy.
This is absolute craziness.
This is the highest
level of football.
And to the average
person this would just
seem like utter unpreparedness.
There's no part of this
that should be happening.
But luckily I was able
to have a background that
taught me how to prepare,
taught me how to take those five
days in the hotel
and transition it
into being able to play on
Sunday and lean on the lessons
that I've learned the
10 years prior to that
and was able to step out there
and play in a game that Sunday.
And then play in the next week
versus the Bills in a playoff
game.
So just kind of a quick
synopsis on some of the things
that this college has taught me.
And then the perseverance
side is just not quitting,
not giving up.
Like I said in that video, and
it's hard to watch that and not
get emotional with
it, because that
was tough to have to
relearn something completely
just because someone said,
that's what you're doing now.
I really honestly
did want to quit.
I wanted to be done.
And again, that's where
I'm really grateful
for my family, my friends,
the support around me
to get through that and to
reinforce that I could do it,
you just got to give
it time, have a plan,
lean on that
preparedness, and flex
those perseverance muscles.
And it's like anything,
they build up over time.
So anyone here, if there's
one takeaway from tonight,
just be prepared, have
a plan and persevere
through that plan.
And this school definitely
taught me how to do that.
So thank you guys.
Can't forget my award.
And Mr Lantis,
could you make sure
that next time you make sure
the school lunch lady is
on the official transcript?
That's a proud moment in light.
Not too many lunch
ladies can get up here
and accept this award.
[APPLAUSE]
KERRY CUMMINGS: Our next
honoree this evening
is Joy Pullmann,
who happens to be
from the stellar class of 2009.
Joy manages to artfully balance
a career as managing editor
of The Federalist, a web
magazine on politics, policy
and culture, with being a wife
and mother of six children.
Joy also works as
a research fellow
on education policy for
the Heartland Institute.
As the former managing
editor of School Reform
News Joy interviewed
and produced
podcasts with many
of the leading
figures in school reform.
She was also assistant editor
for The American magazine
at the American
Enterprise Institute.
Joy is the 2013-14 recipient
of Robert Novak Journalism
Fellowship for in-depth
reporting on Common Core
National Education standards.
Joy's accomplished
journalism has
been published by The New York
Times, Washington Examiner,
The Weekly Standard, Washington
Times, Milwaukee Journal
Sentinel, Salt Lake Tribune,
National Review online,
Real Clear Policy, and
various other US newspapers
and outlets.
Joy has written a series of
research and commentary reports
on the Parent Tiger, a new
school reform idea sweeping
the country, and is co-author
with Joseph L. Bast,
The Parent Trigger--
Justification and
Design Guidelines,
Heartland Institute, 2012.
Joy has taught middle and
high school students history,
literature and debate, and has
authored high school public
speaking curriculum.
She has traveled nationwide
to speak at prominent venues,
including CPAC.
The National Right
to Life convention,
and statewide
education conferences.
She has been guest on
numerous talk shows,
including Fox and Friends,
The John Stossel Show,
and Wall Street Journal's
Opinion Journal.
Joy graduated from
Hillsdale with an English
major and journalism
concentration.
She lives in Indiana
with her husband,
Nathaniel, also a 2009 Hillsdale
graduate, and their six
children.
Please give your
attention to the screen
to meet our Distinguished
Alumni honoree, Joy Pullmann.
JOY PULLMANN: My
name is Joy Pullmann,
and I'm a mother of six kids.
And I'm the executive
editor at The Federalist.
I get up at 5:30.
I may have 6,000 words to
edit it between 6:00 and 8:00
AM, may have 50 emails
to answer as well.
Then I head to the kitchen
to see what state it's
in with all of my children
hanging from the chandeliers--
we don't have a chandeliers.
1:30-2 o'clock is nap
time, and then I'm working.
I get a lot from young
women, how do you do it?
I say, try not to
if you can help it.
Looking at all the college
options that I had,
why was I going to college
in the first place?
I was going to college
to be educated,
to take the talents that I
had and make the most of it.
I had a gut feeling that
at Hillsdale is where
I would get the best education.
The only thing I wish that
would have been better
about my Hillsdale
experience was me.
Well, you know you're
18 years old and stupid.
I was an English major, and I
knew that from the beginning.
I love to write.
What I loved really about
reporting in college
was being a conduit for
other people's stories.
How do you get
people interested?
How do you make sure
it's organized clearly?
All of those kind of
bits about the craft.
After Hillsdale,
I did huge amounts
of on-the-ground reporting.
I was one of the earliest
people to even pay
any attention to this
thing called Common Core.
It came to me from the
grassroots from a mom.
She called me one day and said,
why aren't there any reporters
covering this thing
called Common Core I
think this was 2012 or 2013.
It was before this became
a huge grassroots issue.
She was saying, my local school
district is talking about it
and I tried to go to a
public meeting about it
and they wouldn't let me in.
I was instantly, on her behalf,
wondering, OK, this is weird.
This shouldn't happen.
Government 101, the
people are allowed
to go to public meetings.
I also tried to get
into that meeting.
They wouldn't talk
to me about it
or let me know
anything about it.
I just published a
story about the fact
that they weren't letting
anyone do that information.
And I got deluged with
emails from people saying,
we heard about this, too.
What is this thing?
I happened to be someone just
doing basic journalism when
no other outlets were doing
basic journalism on this thing
that really aimed to completely
overhaul and nationalize
American education.
Because of that, I got a
huge following, huge amount
of readership, and that
turned into a book.
Then it started getting
huge media attention
and became a thing that
even eventually Donald Trump
started talking about.
Reporting on Common Core
played into our decision
to start a school.
People need to be more
and better educated.
The education is a
formation of a human soul,
and the kind of souls that
you have in your country
determine whether it
can be self-governing.
And I want my children
to be self-governing
and I want their neighbors
to be self-governing.
So we started Redeemer
Classical School in 2016.
And it was one-room
schoolhouse then.
Now we're a four-room
schoolhouse.
My husband is the
headmaster of the school
and I'm the executive
editor at The Federalist.
When you have a heart
commitment to the things that
are good, for me it's
really got me through a lot.
I mean, doing all
the things that I do
has been basically a
battle the whole time.
So you don't have the heart
to fight without someone
having shown you what's
worth fighting for.
And so that's what I really got
from the classes at Hillsdale.
Taught me what to love, rather
than fighting and bitterness.
Dr. Sundahl was one of my
freshman English professors
and then I took him, of
course, a bunch of other times.
The things that he would
talk about in class
were just so
touching that I would
sit in the back of his class
and cry as quietly as I could.
I think of Hillsdale as
kind of like the shining
city on a hill.
It's this beautiful place that
is so unlike almost everywhere
else that we have in the world.
And of course it's
not a perfect place,
but it has so many excellencies
all together in one place.
And people have
worked over centuries
and they sacrificed
to make that possible.
So you can go there
and get refreshed,
you can go there and have hope.
Our country is in
really dangerous times.
Through my work, you see some of
that grave danger in Hillsdale
is for me what gives
me so often the courage
to get out there and
keep taking swings.
Right when I graduated,
I really wished
I could go back and
do it all over again.
[APPLAUSE]
KERRY CUMMINGS: OK Joy, on
behalf of Alumni Association
of Hillsdale College,
it's my great honor
to present you with the
Distinguished Alumni
Award in Journalism.
Congratulations.
[APPLAUSE]
JOY PULLMAN: Well,
Hillsdale made me a writer
and my husband a
teacher, so they are not
giving me this award for all the
big checks that we write them.
All the big checks that we
have we put into the school
pretty much.
But as I was thinking about
talking to you all tonight,
I did think about
some checks that
really mattered a lot to me
that have come to Hillsdale.
They came by the hand
of my father, who
wrote his portion of that
6% for my college tuition.
He was unable to
be here tonight,
but I know that he's
watching so I wanted
to recognize the contributions
that my father made and made
it possible for me to go to
Hillsdale in the first place.
Now I know what my father did
to earn that tuition money.
I'm the daughter of a
farmer, so when I was a child
I would see him come home.
Sometimes I would hear from
my mother he'd come home
at midnight, gone
back out 3:00 AM
to check on the
irrigation pumps,
and I would see him
sometimes come back
from what they call the grain
bins covered in white dust,
smelling really, really awful.
And when I came to
school here and I
knew that what my father
had done to make it possible
for me to be here,
that is why I didn't
spend a lot of time partying.
So although perhaps
those checks were
small in the scheme of things,
they matter a lot to me
and I want to thank all of
you for your 6% or maybe more
that you have given
to make it possible.
And I want to say especially
thanks, Dad, for what you did.
Because without you
having done that,
I wouldn't be here right now.
So this is really for you Dad.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
I also wanted to
recognize people who are
as important to me as family.
So another one of the
most glorious things
about my Hillsdale
experience was the people,
was the friendships that
we made here on campus.
And even though you
heard about my bio
and it sounds probably really
great and people kind of
sauce those out to
make them look better.
So I've flown to New York
City to go on Fox News.
But you know what really is
much, much more important
than any of the things on my
bio is seeing the faces that
are right here at this table.
I'm looking at each one of
these people who most of whom we
went to college same class.
Well, maybe I won't.
I was about to say personal
things about all of you.
You know who you are.
People at this table
have written checks
for our school to
start even if it
wasn't possible for their
kids to go to the school.
People at this
table have shown up
when I was flat on my back sick,
picked up my children for me.
They got an email from me saying
I'm going to get this award,
I can't believe it, you want
to come have some free wine?
Just kidding.
We're not that low anymore,
we just used to be in college.
So I mean, there's
nothing that's
more important than the
people at that table.
And I would rather have their
honor and their presence
and their esteem far more than
pretty much anything else.
So that's who I'm here for
tonight and I thank you
all for coming.
And thank you to Dr. Arnn and
for the college for this honor.
I don't know that I
deserve it, but I'll
do my best to be worth--
to use your name well.
So thank you all.
[APPLAUSE]
KERRY CUMMINGS: Thank you, Joy.
Receiving our third
Distinguished Alumnus Award
this evening is Howard
Smith, class of 1968.
Howard was born in Dayton, Ohio.
He earned a Bachelor
of Arts in history
with a minor in
business from Hillsdale.
He was involved in a number
of campus activities,
including Delta Tau
Delta fraternity,
and was a member of both the
football and track teams.
During his freshman year.
Howard met Pamela
Norris, class of '68.
They married in 1971.
Pamela passed away in 2013
after 42 years of marriage.
After graduation, Smith
spent the next four years
serving his country in the
United States Coast Guard.
In 1973, he went to
work for Pam's family
business, the Wilson
Bohannon Lock Company.
Howard spent the first 22
years of his 48-year career
at Wilson Bohannon in the
accounting department.
In 1995 he became
president and CEO.
During this time he earned an
MBA from Ashland University.
The company is proud to be a
100% American-made manufacturer
of brass padlocks
and locking devices
that can be found
all over the world.
Howard and Pam's two
daughters, Sarah Smith Wrastle
'08 and Trish Smith, as well as
the son-in-law Aaron Wrastle,
are the seventh generation
to work for the company.
Making a difference in his
local community of Marion, Ohio,
has always been a high
priority for Howard.
He has served on
numerous boards,
including the Convention and
Visitors Bureau, the Red Cross,
and the YMCA.
He's the past president
of the Marion Rotary Club,
Marion Can-Do Development board,
and the YMCA endowment board.
He currently serves on the
Marion Can-Do and Marion
General Hospital boards.
He's a member of the
Manufacturers Council,
the Industrial Club, and Rotary.
Smith and the Wilson
Bohannon Lock Company
have been honored
in recent years.
In 2018, he was inducted
into the Lock Collectors
Hall of Fame, and in 2019
received a Lifetime Achievement
Award from the Conway
Family Business Center
in Columbus, Ohio.
In 2020, the Wilson
Bohannon Lock Company
was chosen to represent Ohio
at the fourth annual Made
in America product
showcase at the White House
with President Trump.
Please give your
attention to the screen
to our distinguished alumnus
honoree, Howard Smith.
HOWARD SMITH: First you listen,
and you learn, and you watch,
and you wait your opportunity.
And then when you're given
opportunity you do the best
you possibly can with
that opportunity.
It's easy to be successful
when all the times are good.
It's when the times
are not good and how
do you bridge that to where
the time started getting good
again?
And I believe if
you apply yourself
the American dream is
possible for anybody today.
My name is Howard Smith.
I'm president of the
Wilson Bohannon Lock
Company, Marion, Ohio.
My wife's grandfather,
Mr. Wilson Bohannon Tway
came through here
on a troop train,
stopped at a canteen stop and
remembered the friendliness
of the people in Marion, so
here is where we came in 1926
and here is where we are
today, almost 100 years later
with about 70 employees,
making padlocks that
are used all over the world.
We're a seven-generation
family business
and very proud to be
100% American made.
Went to high school in
Dayton, Ohio, and about 95%
of my high school class
goes on to college.
So my parents are going crazy at
the end of the whole situation.
All my friends are
enrolled somewhere,
and where's my son going to go?
But you know Hillsdale,
with the conservative values
and the student guide,
it just rang a bell.
This is beautiful.
And they said, this is
where we want you to go.
I met my wife my
third week at school.
Her great-great grandfather
started the company
in Brooklyn, New York in
1860 with his son Todd
in his shed behind their house.
She didn't want to
be in the business,
she wanted to be
part of the business,
and so she was on the
board of directors.
She was a guidance
counselor Mary
Catholic for over 30 years.
She loved her school,
she loved her community,
she loved this company,
and people just loved Pam.
She was kind, loving,
just a big heart.
There's always a place for any
student to come to the panel
and talk to her
about any situation.
And her passion for
Wilson Bohannon company
was powerful and infectious.
Everybody knew how much
she love this place
and we built that legacy
with my two daughters.
And sadly she was
she passed away
after 42 years of marriage.
What better way could
you carry on her memory
and it be something she had so
much pride in, this company?
We make over 5,000 locks a
day, with most [INAUDIBLE]
all made to order to the exact
specification of our customers.
There's no lock manufacturer
like this in America today
that can do the things we can
do with the tolerance we can do.
So I'm proud of that,
proud that we're
made in this country, proud
that the symbol like Hillsdale
talks about, the
conservative values
and their Christian
attitude-- that's
the way we run our business,
with a Christian attitude--
and the belief in
the Constitution.
But Hillsdale taught me to
be a good corporate citizen.
I want to give back I want a
place where my daughters can
raise their family.
I want a place where my
employees can feel good
about themselves.
And when you hire people
and you bring people
from other parts of
the country, are you
going to bring them to someplace
they don't want to live?
Hillsdale just is
that signpost, that
guidepost telling us how is
the best way to do things.
I think I said before
the American dream is
alive and well in this country.
And I just want
to be an example.
We're not just a business, we're
a human business with human
people who care, with respect
and dignity of each other
and building a culture that's--
it's powerful.
People who walk
through our factory
say, gee whiz, everybody
has a good attitude,
they like what they do,
they're proud of this company.
Well, it's creating
a corporate culture
that allows people to grow
and be something and be
part of a larger part of
something than just themselves.
It's not just me.
It's all the people
that surround me,
all the people that have
made this a great company.
I couldn't do without
all the people.
And that's what I do.
And I go to the factory
every single day,
I thank our employees,
thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you so very much.
KERRY CUMMINGS:
Howard, on behalf
of the Alumni Association
of Hillsdale College
it's my great honor to present
you with the Distinguished
Alumnus Award for
Outstanding Professional
Achievement in Management.
Congratulations.
[APPLAUSE]
HOWARD SMITH: I want to thank
Hillsdale College and everyone
who was involved in this award
ceremony tonight, especially
Dr. Arnn, for this evening
they made possible.
I want to thank my family and
friends who are here tonight.
I want to thank Penny and
Steve Miller from Columbus.
Penny is a member of the
Pi Beta Phi sorority.
And to Gerry Anne Rocco
from Dayton for all
he love and support.
My daughter Sarah,
who was a student here
and a member of Kappa Kappa
Gamma sorority, and her husband
Aaron, who both work
for our family business.
And to Doug Zimmerman,
from Boise, Idaho, who
was a classmate, an outstanding
cross-country runner,
and a member of the track team.
And lastly Alan and
Beth Shafer from Dayton.
Beth and my wife Pam were
sorority sisters of Chi Omega
sorority.
And Alan and I have
been lifelong friends
Alan was a 1968 class
president and president
of our fraternity
Delta Tau Delta.
I look back on my
life and I ask myself
what the Hillsdale College mean
to me as a student in the '60s?
I wanted to make my
parents proud of me.
I wanted to enjoy
the experience.
I wanted to participate in
as many things as I possibly
could, many activities.
I was a history,
major and a business
minor, student guide
for four years here,
played football and
track and enjoyed--
And I had a chance to
throw the javelin--
something I couldn't do
obviously in high school.
And a member of
the Delta Tau Delta
fraternity, on the leadership
workshop and the union policy
board.
In 2020, our
company was selected
to be the fourth annual Made
in America product showcase
to represent the state of Ohio.
I thought, how could
any award I ever receive
be any greater than this until
I got a call several months ago
and I was told that I was going
to be recipient of this award.
I said this is the most
outstanding thing I've ever--
because I believe so
much in Hillsdale College
and what it means today.
Hillsdale gave me a
foundation for being
a successful businessperson.
After graduating from college,
I spent the next four years
in the US Coast Guard.
And I was married
in 1971 and 1973
I started working for the
Wilson Bohannon Lock Company,
first as an accountant
and then as its president.
Wilson Bohannon looks
a lot different today
than it did back
when I started there
in 1973, almost 50 years ago.
Back then, all we did
was that we assembled.
Today, we're totally integrated,
making all of our manufacturing
parts in one location.
The two most powerful
words I believe in business
today are
communication and love.
I keep every one of our
officers and our staff
included in our plans and our
visions in leading the company.
Showing continuous
love and respect
for all of our
associates is essential.
The top five officers of
Wilson Bohannon Company
have over 180 years'
experience in the lock industry
or our company.
Transitioning from
the sixth generation
to the seventh generation,
my two daughters
and my son-in-law,
I hope someday
that my grandchildren,
or the eighth generation,
will continue on our legacy.
Thank you, Hillsdale
College, for providing me
with these tools I needed to
lead a seven-generation family
business that is proud
to be 100% American made.
[APPLAUSE]
God bless our country.
God bless Hillsdale College as
a defender of our Constitution.
And thank you for this
great honor you've
bestowed upon me tonight.
[APPLAUSE]
KERRY CUMMINGS:
Thank you, Howard.
Receiving our fourth
distinguished award
this evening is Ron
Gladnick, class of 1983.
Ron is the head football
coach at Torrey Pines High
School in San Diego,
California, and former CEO
of Apical Industries,
which manufactures
helicopter flotation systems.
Pretty amazing.
A defensive lineman
for the Chargers,
Ron played on the 1980 and
1982 GLEAC championship teams
and was named All-American.
He was inducted into the
Hillsdale College Athletic
Hall of Fame in 2008.
Ron coached defensive
line for the Chargers
and worked in the college's
advancement office
before moving to
San Diego in 1991.
There he established
Apical Industries,
which grew to more than 500
employees in seven facilities,
producing 90% of the market
share of helicopter flotation
systems.
In 2007 Dart Helicopter Services
acquired the business and Ron
sold his interest in
the company in 2011
but continues to work as a
partner in two aviation parts
companies.
Since 2014, Ron has served
as head football coach
at Torrey Pines High School.
He works tirelessly
with young men,
turning a failing program
into a championship team.
In 2021, Ron led a successful
grassroots campaign
to resume youth
sports competition
in California, which had been
suspended due to COVID-19.
Ron lives in a California beach
community just north of San
Diego with his wife Joanna.
He has two daughters, Karina
and Kayla, and at this point,
I'd like you to turn your
attention to the screen
to meet Ron.
RON GLADNICK: And
the first thing
we teach our ninth graders has
nothing to do with football.
All right, hey, heads up.
Summer's over.
You know it's time
to go to work.
Has everything to do with
how to shake a man's hand
and how to look you in the eye.
And that's where we start.
It has everything to do with
building great young men.
And I believe if you do
that the football will
take care of itself.
Hi, my name is Ron Gladnick,
and I'm the head football coach
at Torrey Pines High School.
At Hillsdale as a
freshman, I had the benefit
of probably playing on
one of the worst football
teams in the history
of Hillsdale College.
We were 3 and 8.
When Coach Dye and
Coach Lowry came
to Hillsdale my
sophomore year we
spent the next three months
at 6 o'clock in the morning
where they had turned the
heat up in the field house,
felt like 110, the
most brutal workouts,
quite frankly to get guys who
weren't committed to leave,
which a bunch of them did.
And then over the
next three years
I was a part of that transition
from being a very bad football
team to being one of the
best Division II football
teams in the country.
I was a business major
and an English minor.
I love a liberal arts
education for that reason.
It creates well-rounded people.
And like I tell everybody
the most valuable thing
about Hillsdale College
is you learn how to learn.
And as a result of
that, I've always
felt I don't care what
environment you put me in,
I am going to learn, and then
I'm going to become competent,
and then I'm going to compete.
My whole adult life I've been
a self-employed entrepreneur.
I've built small companies
into medium-sized companies,
and that entails being
everything from the CEO
to the janitor.
And I would say that
very much sums up
my business experience,
my football experience,
and my life experience.
2006, I brought everybody in
a conference room and said,
look, you guys are brilliant.
I hired all of you.
You're smarter than me.
I'm going to go coach
high school football,
you guys run the company.
And they did a great job.
I always tell
everybody I worked hard
my whole life to getting back
to doing what I love the most.
When I first started coaching,
it was like herding cats.
If you want to be competitive in
high-level California football,
it's 12 months of the year.
We end our season,
we're in the weight room
the following Monday.
And the parents stood up and
said, why are you doing this?
I said, because it's hard.
Because boys need hard.
Because life is hard.
My first season we were 6 and 4.
In '18 we were 12 and 1.
We've won the toughest league
in the county three times.
The expectations are high.
In March 2020, before
our spring break,
we were told school would
be closed for two weeks.
It ended up being
for over a year.
I got more phone calls from kids
in trouble from March of 2020
to March of 2021 than in all of
my previous 14 years combined
and we were right there.
Our kids, after a lift, I
was looking at the kids,
and I don't even know
what came over me,
but I looked at the
kids, I said look,
I'm probably going
to crash and burn,
but I promise you I'm going
to do everything I can
as your head coach
to get sports back.
And that's how it started.
SPEAKER 2: Local coaches,
parents and athletes
say enough is enough.
It's time for change.
It's time to play sports again.
And now they're holding
an event to get the state
to pay attention.
Head football coach at
Torrey Pines High School,
Ron Gladnick.
SPEAKER 3: Ron Gladnick.
SPEAKER 4: Ron Gladnick.
Coach, thank you for
once again joining us.
RON GLADNICK: We started.
We formed six SEAL teams
of parent volunteers
who had different jobs.
I was in charge of
SEAL Team Six, which
was engaging our politicians.
We started an app and we got
1,600 head high school football
coaches in California in the
app and 7,000 assistant coaches.
So 11 days after I started,
it was 4:30 in the afternoon,
my cell phone rang and
it was Gavin Newsom.
Him and I talked for 45 minutes,
and what I left him with
was this.
I said, governor we
are not political.
We do not want to be political.
We want to do the
right thing for kids.
He wanted sports
back, but the mosh pit
of special interests that
you had to work through
to get it back from
that day took five weeks
until we finally got it done.
And as a result, not only did we
get high school football back,
but we got all high
school sports back.
All seasons were played
from March to June.
Youth sports were returned.
It was incredible.
3.3 million kids got to play.
What could be better than that?
At the end of the
day, our whole program
here has nothing to
do with football.
It has everything to do with
building great young men.
And I believe if you do
that, the football will
take care of itself.
And I learned that
from Dick Lowry.
This is stuff I learned
from my college head coach,
my defensive coordinator.
So for me it all started there.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you so much.
KERRY CUMMINGS: Ron, on behalf
of the Hillsdale College Alumni
Association, we present you
with the Distinguished Award
for Outstanding Achievement.
And I'm going to have
to look directly--
I'd forgotten the category.
I lost my page.
But congratulations.
[APPLAUSE]
RON GLADNICK: I've
limited my comments
to two hours and
27 minutes, so--
No.
I've never been one to
reflect on a birthday.
To me, you're the age
you feel and I've always
tried to approach life
feeling young and vibrant and
enthusiastic every single day.
But on September
12th I turned 60,
and it's the first time
I've ever paused in my life
and really reflected on how you
get to a certain place in time.
And what was fascinating
about taking some time
to do that is your whole
life is determined by really
at the end of the day, a
few chance interactions that
change the course of your life.
And I was a young
kid back East getting
ready to sign with Syracuse
University for football who
was not very good.
And John Servini entered my
life, came to recruit me.
My parents are very
conservative, so John--
I will never forget this, I've
told this story 100 times,
he was a much bigger
guy back then--
came into my living room and
sat with my mother and father.
And he crossed his leg and
he balanced a coffee cup
on a little tiny plate on his
thigh and talked to my parents
for--
I kept looking at the cup
going, it's a matter of time,
but he never, the
guy never flinched.
And I forget what day
of the week it was,
but John came, I talked to
my parents, I went to bed,
I woke up the next day,
my mom and dad said,
you're going to
Hillsdale College.
So that was my choice.
And then I got here,
and for a kid back East
coming to the Midwest
for the first time
it was a lot of culture shock.
And it was really different.
And we were a terrible
football team.
I mean really bad.
I mean so bad.
And there are people--
So I always look back, and John
got me to Hillsdale College
and Hillsdale College changed
the course of my whole life.
And then John Wilson, my
advisor, is John here?
Stand up John.
[APPLAUSE]
My first two years here, John
Wilson kept me in school.
Was not only a
mentor and my advisor
but was a friend, a friend who
cared about you personally,
well beyond the scope of his job
as a professor and an advisor.
And there were some bumpy
moments in that first two
years, and John was always a
calming influence and always
was the guy, hey,
it's going to be OK
and we'll move on
to the next thing.
And so, John, you changed
the course of my life
by being a good friend and
being a great history professor
and I appreciate you very much.
My mom and dad are
too frail to travel,
but they're watching tonight,
along with my family.
And I want to thank them all.
I want to thank my mom
and dad for raising us
right, my brother and sister and
I. And I look at our families
now and we spend a lot of
time together and none of that
would have happened
without them.
So they changed the
course of my life.
One of the beautiful things
about Hillsdale for me
is that ability to be put in
any environment and thrive.
And I don't know that people
value that skill set enough
anymore, but it's the
most important thing
this college does.
Because I look at
Jared, I look at you,
I look at all the people that
have spoken here tonight,
and I get the sense you can
be put in any environment
and succeed.
Now Jared I'm older than you,
so my bones creak and stuff,
so I did want to put my
head on your body for a year
and your head on my body so
you can get a preview of what
the future holds.
It's a gift.
I'd like to Thank Jeff
Lantis, because Jeff
does an amazing job of keeping
guys like me who are far
away connected to the college.
And his impact on my
tie to Hillsdale College
has been very, very dramatic.
At the end of the
day Coach Lowry
and Coach Dye, the
professors and the courses
and all the things
that we do here,
again, gave me
the gift to learn.
It was the
organizational efficiency
that Dick Lowry and
Dave Dye taught me
that shaped my business
career, because it was hard.
They treated people with
dignity and respect,
but then they empowered
us to be successful.
And that's the cornerstone
of every single business
I've ever run.
Treat people right.
We had 500 employees.
No one ever punched a
clock in the company, ever.
You had to go to a
baseball game for your kid,
go to a baseball game.
You need it to be an adult and
make decisions about your time,
go ahead, just get
your work done.
And I was always
so proud I would
drive by the facility
at 11 o'clock at night
and there'd be 20 lights
on in the building
because people did the right
thing when given the choice
to do the right thing.
And my experience with the
football team or a company,
a group of adults or
a group of teenagers,
is if you treat them
right, and you love them,
and you look out for
their best interests,
and they know you do, the
lion's share of people
will do the right thing
every single time.
And if I can leave you with
one thought it would be this--
be humble, work
hard, do the best
you can, and at
the end of the day,
when your work is
done, hopefully
we'll leave the Earth in a
better place than we found it.
And if you do that, like me,
because of Hillsdale College,
you too will have
a beautiful life.
I thank you so much.
This is such a humbling
experience for me.
I love being back here.
Fills my soul, with
all the good stuff.
Thank you, Dr. Arnn.
And Dr. Arnn, thank
you for continuously
raising the academic
standards so
that when I'm out
in the world and I
say I went to Hillsdale
College, well,
that's just like the Ivy League,
and I go, yes, yes it is.
So thank you, sir.
God bless.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
LARRY ARNN: I forgot
to thank three people.
But coming up here gives me
a chance to say two things.
One is I'm glad Joy got
the award because otherwise
the entire field would have been
a much better football player
than I ever was.
And also the kids don't
actually walk around
in slow motion on
the college campus,
walking through molasses.
Who I forgot to thank are
Maryann Rotale and Kerry
Cummings, who've been just
tremendous in this job.
And the alumni board
is growing all the time
and it's a blessing to the
college and I'm grateful.
And of course Colleen
is excellent at the job.
[APPLAUSE]
And I don't know if Neil
Cole is going to be any good,
but we have our fingers crossed.
Thank you all for being here.
KERRY CUMMINGS:
Thank you, Dr. Arnn.
Such inspiring stories tonight.
It truly was an honor to
be among these awardees.
And this concludes the
presentation of our awards.
Congratulations to all of you.
And at this time,
I'd like to ask
Colleen to come to the podium
for a few closing remarks.
[APPLAUSE]
COLLEEN MCGINNESS: Thank you.
Well, we have a party
planned afterward
and I know you're all--
I hope you're all,
anxious to get to it.
I hope it becomes a fun night--
not that it isn't
already, but we
have the Hillcats faculty jazz
band who played earlier for us.
They're going to continue
on for a couple of hours.
And we have quite
a few alumni who
are out enjoying a reception
who are going to join and merge
with us for a decades party,
so I hope you'll stay for that.
I have a few more
housekeeping announcements
before we adjourn.
I want to run through a
little bit of what's going
on tomorrow just as a reminder.
But we have the It's The
Pancakes pancake brunch
outside of the chapel
tomorrow from 9:00 to 11:00
in front of Christ Chapel.
The alumni choir will be
practicing with the music
program in the chapel and
will have a brief performance
at noon in Christ Chapel.
The alumni tailgate will
be from noon to 4:00
over by the Sports
Complex and will
feature food, of course beer,
and music from alumna Nicole
Corey's band Arctic Clam.
The football game begins at
4:00 and the first 100 people
to check in at the alumni
tent will receive a discounted
ticket.
Following the game, we'll
be hosting a fifth quarter
reception in the
president's suite
which is inside the Sports
Complex, where we'll
be able to watch
some of the students
mock rock dances if you're
into that kind of thing.
I want to thank Bon Appetit and
the Searle Center team for all
their good work, as well
as the alumni office
team for their effort putting
together this weekend.
I want to particularly
thank Ashley Sallows, who
was the lead planner for all
of our homecoming festivities.
She's worked tirelessly.
Thank you, Ashley.
[APPLAUSE]
I'd like to think Dr.
Arnn and John Servini
for supporting our
alumni outreach ventures
and the alumni office.
Our alumni are a very important
part of the Hillsdale family
and spending time
together will continue
to build that relationship.
So I want you to mark your
calendars for May 19 to 22,
where we will host our second
annual White and Blue Weekend.
And it's a weekend
just for alumni.
If you haven't heard of
it, we had our first White
and Blue weekend this last May.
It was a blast.
There's something for
everyone, including
your kids if you
have them, and lots
of room on campus for alumni
to take over and enjoy campus
and academic life once again.
So please consider joining
us for that this year
if you didn't last here and
also if you did, come back.
It's been such a joy to
welcome you all back home.
I'm always very inspired
by this evening.
It's my favorite
night of the year.
And it's really fun to spotlight
and elevate our alumni.
They're just
fantastic ambassadors
of what Hillsdale does here.
So I'm very proud to do that.
As you know, there's
no place like Hillsdale
and we need the college
now more than ever.
Thank you so much and enjoy
the rest of your evening.
[APPLAUSE]